اهلا بكم طلبهم في عام رئاسته الاول
بالصبر عليه سنه ليروا نتائج عمله ثم
طالبهم اواخر العام الماضي بالصبر لسته
اشهر اخرى فكانت زياده في اسعار الوقود
والمحروقات هي الاعلى منذ بدات اجراءات
رفع الدعم هذا حال المصريين مع الرئيس عبد
الفتاح السيسي ويرتقب ان تتلو هذه الزياده
الجديده موجه غلا في اسعار السلع ستزيد
الضغوط الواقعه على كاهل الاسر المصريه
وتاتي في الذكرى الرابعه لمظاهرات ال 30
من يونيو التي الطريق امام السيسي للرئاسه
وقد اعتبر بعض من ايدوه الخطوه غباء
سياسيا ودعوه للاحتجاج اتابع تقرير محمد
فاوي ثم نبدا النقاش حول التداعيات
الاجتماعيه والسياسيه لزياده اسعار الوقود
في
مصر ان شاء الله اخر الشهر ده
هتكون الدوله خلصت
تدخلها لتقليل الاسعار
بشكل
هكذا تعهد الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي في اواخر عام
2015 بان تنتهي متاعب المصريين مع واحده
من اسوا موجات الغلاء التي تعصف بهم منذ
عقود طويله المفارقه الكبرى انه سرعان ما
عمدت الحكومه المصريه بعد ذلك الى اغراق
عمله البلاد المحليه في موجه تعويم مفاجئه
استجابه لمطالب صندوق النقد الدولي طوعا
او كرها لتهوي القدره الشرائيه لتلك
العمله المحليه لاسوا مستوياتها في
التاريخ الاقتصادي المصري ونسيب الناس
تتفرج علينا ولما نيجي نقول له انا هزود
عليك التذكره جنيه يقول لك انا غلبان مش
قادر صحيح وانا كمان غلبان مش قادر ورغم
ان صندوق النقد ذاته اقر بانه اخطا في
التنبؤ بالتداعيات القاسيه لهذه التدابير
الا ان الدوله بدت وكانها تصر على المضي
قدما في سياساتها التقشف
لتتفاقم موجه الغلاء الى مستويات صارت
تنذر بخلخال المنظومه الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه ومن ثم القيميه المصريه فقد
رفعت الحكومه اسعار الوقود بنسب تصل الى
100% في بعض المنتجات في اطار ما وصفته
بخطه ترمي لاعاده هيكله دعم المواد
البتروليه هذه النوعيه من السياسات
الاقتصاديه التي وصفت كثيرا بانها اكثر
قسوه واجحاف من السياسات الاقتص صيه التي
اطاحت بالرئيس المخلوع حسني مبارك بدت
وكانها تنثر بالمزيد من اهتراء الطبقه
المتوسطه المصريه فتصد الذي اصاب هذه
الطبقه التي تعد العصبه الرئيسيه لتماسك
اي مجتمع افضى الى تسارع سقوط بعض شرائحها
الى هاويه الفقر فقد قفز عدد الذين يعيشون
تحت خط الفقر في البلاد الى اكثر من 37
مليون شخص حسب التقديرات الحكوميه كما
حذرت م سات ماليه عالميه كبرى من ان مصر
صارت واحده من اسوا دول العالم في توزيع
الثروات حيث صار اغنى 10 في من السكان
يستحوذون على اكثر من 70 في من الثروات
الشعب المصري خصوصا من
مصلحش عموما يجعل من بني ادمول تاريخيا
افضا سياع الرئيس المصري الراحل انور
السدات لشروط اقتصاديه مماثله فرضها صندوق
النقد الدولي ابان حقبه السبعينيات من
القرن الماضي الى اندلاع ما سمي بانتفاضه
الخبز وهي الانتفاضه التي كادت تطيح
بالسادات نفسه لولا نزول الجيش للشوارع
ولعل هذا ما قد يدفع كثيرين للاعتقاد بانه
اذا كان التاريخ يشي بان للمصريين باعا
طويلا في الصبر السياسي والاجتماعي
والاقتصادي الا ان قوانين علم الاجتماع
تحذر دوما من اجتماع القهر السياسي مع
الكبت الاقتصادي في م واحده فمحله هذه
الحسبه قد تكون الارجح انفجارا اجتماعيا
ولو بعد حين او هكذا يشي التاريخ السياسي
[موسيقى]
للامم عايش نص ميت وال ميت من
س ينضم الينا من اسطنبول اشرف دوابه استاذ
التمويل والاقتصاد في جامعه اسطنبول ومن
القاهره عبر سكايب محمود ابراهيم نائب
رئيس مركز الاتحاديه للدراسات ومن القاهره
ايضا عبر الهاتف الكاتب الصحفي جمال الجمل
اهلا بضيوفي الكرام وابدا معك سيد جمال
لنرصد معك ردود الفعل الاوليه في مصر على
هذه الاجراءات المتخذه خاصه من قبل الفئه
المعنيه بشكل مباشر بهذه
الاجراءات ساخره مش غاضبه مساء ال لانها
كانت متوقعه
يعني الايقاف الاخير
لمقال اللي كتبته بعنوان لماذا فرض السيسي
الطوارئ كان في اشاره الى انه فرض الطوارئ
كان متعلق بالشريحه الثانيه من رفع الدعم
اللي هي احنا يعني مرينا بها صباح اليوم
وبالتالي المساله
متوقعه فكره التوقيت ودلالاته وفكره النسب
بتاعه رفع الدعم يعني اهم من القرار نفسه
لانه قرار معروف والسياسات واضحه هي
سياسات عقاب هذا الشعب لصالح الفئه
القليله الحاكمه يعني امنيا واقتصاديا
يعني على المستوى المالي والعسكري هل معنى
ذلك بانها لم تخلف اي ردوده فعل باعتبارها
متوقعه كما
ذكرت زي ما انا سمعت في التقرير من شويه
ردود الافعال دائما في مصر في دراسه
التاريخ الاجتماعي للثورات بتبقى هبات
غاضبه غير متوقعه يعني انت تتنبا ان الشعب
المصري هيخرج بكره غضبا على كذا لا ما
بيحصلش لكن فجاه لسبب ابسط من كده بكتير
بيثور و بيتاح ما في طريقه لكن المؤشرات
حتى الان احنا بنمر بحاله يعني بيسموها في
يعني تعب المعادن يعني الشعب المصري منهك
على مستويات كثيره
جدا فكره انتظار الثوره في الميادين يعني
المشاهد ال مليونيات اللي كنا
بنشوفها يعني ماهياش واقعيه بالدرجه اللي
احنا ممكن نتخيلها طيب الفيسبوك معبر عن
درجه من
النقمه يعني ممكن يبقى الغضب الكامن ناس
ممكن يبقى ماسك موبايله او قاعد على
الكيبورد وبيتكلم بمر شديده
وسخريه
سعك جمال ساعود لك ضيفي من ايضا من
القاهره محمود ابراهيم كيف وجدت هذه الهد
التي قدمها الرئيس السيسي للمصريين وخاصه
جمهور ال 30 من يونيو في الذكرى الرابعه
لمظاهرات ال 30 من
يونيو يعني دينا مش هديه انا يعني حضرتك
يعني تستخدم لفظ ساخر لكن دي قرارات
اقتصاديه ليها خطه معينه حتى اقرها
البرلمان بعيدا عن الرئيس وتم مناقشتها
فيه ا دي زي جراحه صعبه لكن الشعب او
الحكومه مضطره ليها لانه عشان تحسن اوضاع
الناس ا طبعا هذه الاجراءات محتاجه
اجراءات ثانيه بكل تاكيد هل الحكومه جاده
في اتخاذ الاجراءات الثانيه مش مش واضح
انه ده ماشي لكن في النهايه اللي حصل ده
ما نقدرش نقوله انه غلط لكن هل اللي هيحصل
بعده صح ولا لا ده اللي احنا مستنينه الا
يكون امام الحكومه خيارات اخرى خاصه وان
صندوق النقد الدولي اعترف بان
ما طلبه بما يتعلق بالجنيه المصري
وتحرير العمله فيما يتعلق بالجنيه المصري
كانت قرارات خاطئه ولم تكن مدروسه في
الحاله المصريه وبالتالي هل كان امام
الحكومه اجراءات اخرى لا تجعل الصدمه بهذا
المستوى فيما يتعلق بالشارع المصري ورجل
الشارع في
مصر طبعا قدام الحكومه طول الوقتي في
خيارات ثانيه يعني انا اتصور مثلا انه كان
على الحكومه انها تشجع استثمارات وتفتح
السوق بشكل احسن من كده فيبقى في حصيله
ضربيه تغطي عجز الموازنه اللي هم بيحققوا
بيه ا ربما ده يبد يعني بياخد وقت شويه
لكن كان اجراء لو ابتدوا فيه من سنتين كان
زمان الوضع افضل منذ المؤتمر الاقتصادي
مثلا فاه في طبعا اجراءات تانيه لكن هي
الحكومه خدت الاجراء الصعب اللي هو في يوم
من الايام انت هتعمله في كل الاحوال يب
ربما خدت في روط غير مواتيه لكن يعني هي
تكلفه القرار كبيره هتبقى على المواطن لكن
في النهايه يعني دي اجراءات ماشه فكتها
ونامل ان الامور تتحسن يعني طيب سيد اشرف
دواب بضيفي من اسطنبول بلغه اقتصاديه كما
شاهدنا قبل قليل في التقرير الرئيس السيسي
قال عندما سئل او هناك تعليق من مواطن
قاله بانني غلبان او باننا من الغلابه رد
السيسي وقال نحن ايضا غلابه في اشاره
لحكومه هل هذا الرد بلغه الاقتصاد مقنع من
مسؤول في توصيف حاله يعاني منها
المواطن طبعا هو الرد غير مقنع لو احنا
نظرنا اقتصاديا هنلاقي زي التقرير ماتكلم
حضرتك في نوع من التفاوت اصلا في الثروه
موجود داخل مصر ومن ضمن الناس برض فئه
خاصه هي ايضا بتستا سر بالسلطه والثروه ده
موجود في مصر لكن الواقع العملي بيقول ان
القرارات دي انا خليني ارجع للبعد
الاقتصادي اللي قالته الحكومه مش هجيب
حاجه من عندي مؤقتا الحكومه قالت زي ما
قال وزير البترول وقال نائب وزير الماليه
قال ان الحكومه الغرض من هذه الاجراءات هو
توفير من 35 ل 40 مليار جنيه مصري وماحدش
عارف ال 35 و40 مليار دول هيروحوا فين بعد
كده الامر الثاني هم خمس اسباب رئيسيه
قالوا بغرض تخفيض عجز الموازنه الى نسبه
99% الامر الثالث اللي تتكلموا فيه برده
وده مذكور في بيان المالي لموازنه العامه
للدوله ان هم حسبوا سعر البترول دلوقتي
البرميل على 55 دولار بعد ما كان محسوب
على 40 دولار في الموازنه اللي قبل كده
ايضا قالوا من ضمن الحاجات ارتفاع الدولار
نتيجه لتعويم سعر الصرف ده الاسباب
الرئيسيه وفي سبب كمان مهم جدا وهو تنفيذ
تعليمات الصندوق ليه لان الصندوق عشان يدي
الشريحه الثانيه اللي هي حوالي مليار و250
مليون طلب منهم هذه الاجراءات فنستطيع
نقول ان كل هذه الامور جت نتيجه لتنفيذ
تعليمات صندوق النقد الدولي صح صندوق
الناقد الدولي هو الدعم رشطه لكن ما توقعش
ان الامور تسوق بالصوره دي لكن هو هذه
الروشيته ايضا يريد تنفيذها بالصوره اللي
احنا شايفينها النهارده وموضوع الحمايه
الاجتماعيه اللي تم النهارده في حدود 75
مليار جنيه مصري اللي ضعته الحكومه هي
داتهم باليمين وخدت اضعفهم بالشمال نتيجه
لمثل هذه القرارات اللي جت في توقيت غير
مناسب هي القرارات معروفه انها هتحصل لكن
جت في توق اشرف يبدو ان الحكومه والرئيس
السيسي في تطبيق وصفه صندوق الن النقد
الدولي في حال واصلت الحكومه والرئيس في
نهج وصفه صندوق النقد الدولي ماذا عن
تبعات هذه هذه
الخطوه سؤال مهم جدا تبعات الخطوه دي
الناس عايشاها وبتعيش اللي اسوا منها
تبعات الخطوه اللي تمت دلوقتي حاليا دي
شيء طبيعي مزيد من ارتفاع الاسعار نتيجه
لمثل هذه القرارات خاصه ان الوقود يدخل في
كل السلع يدخل في الخبز يدخل في المواصلات
يدخل في المنسوجات يدخل في اي شيء ففي
ارتفاع في الاسعار ارتفاع الاسعار ده هوت
في ظل الظروف اللي احنا عايشينها النهارده
هيدي الى زياده في تكاليف الاستثمار ايضا
هدي الى مزيد من البطاله هيدخلنا في حاجه
اسمها ركود تضخمي احنا اصلا بادئين في
الدخول فيه دي كل دي خطوات احنا مشناها
هدي ايضا الى زياده تكلفه الواردات وقله
الصادرات المصريه ننتيجه لارتفاع التكلفه
بتاعه الصادرات المصريه كل دي من ضمن
الاثار في في النهايه خلاص فنعيش للاسف
الشديد في لولب في هذه الصوره وده ممكن
يؤدي الى نوع من الضغط الاجتماعي الذي
يؤدي في نهايه المطاف الى الانفجار زي
التقرير بتاعكم اتكلم بهذه الصوره وده شيء
متوقع مش شيء بعيد لان الانفجار ب ليه
مقدمات بس يحصل هذا ده شيء ماق ضفي من
الطره سيد جمال الجمل اين الاحزاب
السياسيه في مصر اين البرلمان المصري اين
النقابات مما
يجري والله احنا واصلين ل يعني مرحله
هشاشه سياسيه وتململ اجتماعي
كبير الاحزاب بتحاول انها تعمل يعني
حراك عاقل للمواجهه لانه الشارع مش هيقدر
يستوعب يعني المغامرات العنيفه لانه
التكلفه الامنيه اللي اتعملت في في في ذهن
الشارع طوال السنوات اللي فاتت بحجه
الارهاب يعني اصبحت ذريعه تخويف كبيره جدا
في في ذهن الشارع السؤال البديل يعني
دائما لما بتتكلم مع مواطن عن انه يتظاهر
او يطيح بنظام وتعلم درس بعد كده في انه
طيب وماذا عن اليوم التالي للثوره يعني
مين اللي هيجي هيجي حد من نفس النظام عشان
مبارك يتم استنساخه من جديد في اسئله يعني
محتاجه اجابات عميقه
وهادئه لم يجد الشارع المصري اجابه عليها
اوليس سيد جمال اوليس الوضع المصري امام
حاله اخطر مما وصفت الان الحديث عن ثوره
الجياع وليس ثوره النخب تطرح الاسئله
بالذي يجب وماذا عن اليوم الذي يلي قد
يكون هناك في ظل هذه الظروف ثوره جياع
وبالتالي حلا يعني ث ثوره الجياع هو
ارتباك امني يعني لا يصحح مسيره لا
المجتمع ولا الدوله يعني نوع من انواع
الغضب العشوائي اللي مش ؤدي وده في تخوف
عاقل في الشارع مصري منه يعني المصريين مش
محتاجين ان هم يصوروا من اجل لا شيء كما
حدث في الخمس سنوات اللي فاتت محتاجين عنم
قدر وده معطل شويه لفكره الثوره لكنه
بيطمنا انه الثوره القادمه ستكون اكثر
جذريه طيب سيد محمود ابراهيم هل يراهن
الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي على القبضه
الامنيه مواصله حاله الطوارئ في البلاد
وبالتالي لا يمكن لاي احد ان يكسر هذه الح
الامنيه وبالتالي يتيح له اتخاذ مزيد من
الاجراءات يعني انا اتصور انه كان كان في
درس في مصر في السب ثمان سنين اللي فاتوا
فهو انه اولا القبده الامنيه ما بتمنع لو
في حراك اجتماعي او سياسي يعني كانت
مافتكرش ان النظام ده اقوى من النظام حل
العدلي مثلا الامني يعني النظام الامني
لكن انا في رايي واتفق مع الاستاذ جمال
الجبل ان راان هنا رهان سياسي هو بيحط
راسماله السياسي في هذا الامر و قال انه
انا شعبيتي هتنزل وانا متوقع دو انه هو
عارف ان الناس مش هتخرج مش لان الناس
خايفه من الامن ولكن لانه الناس زي ما
الاستاذ جمال الجمل اوضح انه الناس ليها
حساب سياسي بيقول انه احنا مش هنقف الى
المجهول مش هننزل في الشارع عشان حد يركب
المظاهرات بتاعتنا ويحقق مكاسب للسلطه
بتاعته هو ف وطبعا مع ضعف الاحزاب
السياسيه وضعف التنظيمات السياسيه
الموجوده
ا
يعني لا يتوقع اي حراك من اي نوع وبالتالي
المسار اللي احنا ماشيين فيه هو انه الناس
هتتحمل هذه التكلفه ا كل اللي علينا ان
احنا نعمله ان احنا نحاول نقلل من التكلفه
اللي الناس هتتحمل يعني يعني انا اتصور
مثلا انه لو كانت الحكومه اتخذت بعض
الاجراءات الجاده في التقشف مثلا بدل هذه
الامور زي مثلا انها تقفل مبير ومش عارف
ايه كل الحاجات اللي بيصرفوا الجرايب
القوميه اللي بتاخ مليارات ومليارات سي
سيد جمال كان حس سيد جمال بايجاز لو تكرمت
وصفه صندوق النقد الدولي متواصله حتى ربما
السنتين القديمه الى حين الرفع الكلي لدعم
الحكومه بالنسبه للمشتقات النفطيه هل لدى
الشارع المصري القدره على التحمل في ظل ما
وصفه ضيفي قبل قليل من القاهره لا لا لا
لا لا هو مشوار التبعيه الطويل اللي بدا
في منتصف السبعينات ويواصل قطار التبعيه
مسيرته يعني بطريقه مهينه لتاريخ مصر
وكرامه المصريين وعندنا مواقف كتيره في
دائ المصري بيثور في لحظه يعني على كرامته
25 يناير لم تكن يعني مثل 77 او او غضبه
86 كانت مظاهره كرامه قبل ان تكون مظاهره
خبز وبالتالي سؤال الكرامه هو السؤال
الاعلى في الشارع المصري و بيتعارض مع
فكره التبعيه المذله اللي احنا وصلنا ليها
واللي هي منعكسه في السياسه والاقتصاد كله
انا عايز اقول انه مش معنى انه الجماهير
مش هتخرج في الشوارع مافيش ردود افعال لكن
هتبقى ردود افعال مفاجئه وموجعه خارج
السياق يعني انت بتغذي فكره الارهاب بتغذي
الحلول الفرديه من عنف فردي او سرقات او
اغتيالات او كلام من هذا النوع وده الخطر
اللي بيهدد كيان الدوله المصريه وبيهدد
الحلول التقليديه اللي عاش عليها المجتمع
المصري لفترات طويله وبالتالي هو الجنون
بيواجه بجنون يعني انا ماقدرش اعمل
سيناريو متسق للمستقبل في مجتمع طيب يعني
لم يبقى معي الا وقت قليل سيد اشرف دوابه
باعتقادك هل تواصل الحكومه المصريه
اجراءاتها رغم الوضع الاقتصادي الحالي
بالنسبه للمواطن
المصري اعتقد ان الحكومه ستمارس هذه
السياسه وتستمر فيها هوده واضح تماما حتى
في 15/8 حضرتك هيغلق الباب بالنسبه
للبطاقات التموينيه وهيحاول يحذفوا حوالي
حوالي 40 مليون مواطن زي ما قال وزير
التموين بلسانه ثم بعد ذلك يصفى الموضوع
على 30 مليون ويبدا يصفهم بعد كده فاعتقد
ان الدوله ماشيه في هذا الموضوع وفقا
لتعليمات صندوق النقد الدولي وستظل تسير
في هذا الوضع لان انا وجهه نظري كتحليل
اقتصادي في هذا الموضوع النظره هنا ليست
نظره قوه اقتصاديه ولكن هي نظره قوه
عسكريه فهنا يغيب العقل ويصبح الايه قوه
الد هي الاساس في التحكم في هذا الموضوع
وده حدي في النهايه الى مزيد من الفقر
ومزيد من الانفجار من اسطنبول اشرف دوابه
استاذ التمويل والاقتصاد في جامعه اسطنبول
وكذلك اشكر ضيفي من القاهره عبر سكايب
محمود ابراهيم نائب رئيس مركز الاتحادي
للدراسات وكذلك ضيفي من القاهره عبر
الهاتف الكاتب الصحفي جمال الجمل في الملف
الثالث من حصاد نناقش تناقش رولا ابراهيم
ابعاد قرارات الرئيس اليمني عبد الربو
منصور هادي اقاله محافظين محسوبين على ما
ي سم المجلس الانتقالي الجنوبي